Excuse me, sir.
-What?
-We're hungry.
I could eat.
Surf Shop, Surfer Boy Pizza.
This is Argyle speaking.
We make everything fresh
here at Surfer Boy,
except for our pineapple,
which comes from a can.
There's a 4 p.m. showing
of Police Academy 3.
Could be fun.
Maybe we just
stay home today.
What is this?
What, you guys just gonna
mope around all break?
No one's moping.
It's just the movie's
supposed to suck.
-I was with my band.
-Corroded Coffin!
-Corroded…
-Oh, my God. Yes.
-You do remember.
-Of course.
With a name like that,
how could I forget?
I don't know.
You're a freak.
Parties,
or a game
where you toss balls
into laundry baskets!
-Loser!
-You want something, freak?
It's not exactly
the Ritz, is it?
Right, Doctor Zhivago.
It's a double VHS.
It's long,
but that's because
it's filled with action
and romance and
a little bit of suspense.
Ozzy Osborne?
Black Sabbath?
He… He bit a bats head off.
-I don't--
-No? Doesn't matter.
Very metal, what you did.
That's all I'm saying.
Did you know, peanut butter
is banned in motherland?
I buy for
dollar-thirty here,
sell for $20 there.
Your mother must
be very proud.
Someone has been
in my peanut butter.
Very popular, as I said.
-Michael Myers.
-Oh, yeah.
Michael Myers.
If you ask me,
Victor's like that.
There's a real bogeyman.
Is that what you call this?
Did I survive?
No, I assure you,
I am still
very much in hell.
-Hey, Steve…
-Did you guys see this?
-How many phones you have?
-Someone was murdered.
How many phones do you have?
We've got two. Why?
Technically three, if you
count Keith's in the back.
Yeah, three works.
Okay, so I asked
for vomit green
and I got vomit green.
Isn't that awesome?
I said, turn it off.
If you say so.
Wipeout!
My name is Lady Applejack,
and I'm a chaotic good,
half-elf rogue, Level 14.
And I will sneak behind
any monster you throw my way
and stab them in the back
with my poison-soaked kukri.
And I'll smile
as I watch them die
a slow, agonising death.
So, we gonna do this,
or we gonna
keep chitchatting
like this is your mummy's
book club?
You open for something
a little more challenging?
-C?
-G?
-G, yeah. U…
-U…
-A… R…
"Guar"?
"Guar…"
"Guar…"
-"Guard."
-Guarded.
Guarded, okay.
Watergate's guarded.
Perfect, yes. Yes. Yes!
Twelve Ricks already
have accounts here.
-That's a lotta Ricks.
-Bingo.
-Lipton?
-Spelled like the tea.
2121 Holland Road.
That's out by Lovers Lake.
Middle of nowhere.
It's a perfect
place to hide.
Truly wonderful.
What an inspiring story.
We are all time-travellers
if you think about it.
For example, this week
is going very fast,
I think
because I am so busy.
I have to make something
called a "visual aid".
I hope Mrs. Gracie
will give me an A.
I'm running
out of time here.
Just hold your horsies,
Dusty-bun.
-Do you see it?
-Yeah, I see it.
-Yikes, Dusty.
-Yeah.